-We're back, and my family
is here with us.
And another development
this year is, Josh,
you and I have started
doing a podcast
called "Family Trips
with the Meyers Brothers."
-Yeah.
-It's been a delight.
The nicest part about it for me
is we get to spend an hour
each week talking
with each other.
Here's a -- You guys
were guests on the show.
-Yep.
-Which was very fun.
Here's a photo
we have of you guys.
And this is a really --
This is a great picture.
I showed this to my boys,
and Ashe said,
"What happened to them?"
[ Laughter ]
Now, do you feel --
We talk about you guys a lot
on this podcast because we're
talking about family trips
with our guests, and then
ultimately ours come out.
Do you feel as though you're
being accurately portrayed
when Josh and I talk
about you on the podcast?
-I don't know.
I don't get that thing
about we spill water everywhere.
-Yeah. Josh, do you want
to say what happens
when they come to your house?
-The kitchen is soaked.
Constantly.
They -- The sink,
the coffeemaker.
The -- I mean, like,
we did redo the kitchen
a couple years ago,
and it used to be small tiles.
-Yeah, it used to be
everything was on an angle.
-Well, now we can
at least just, like,
wipe everything into the sink,
which is a godsend.
-Yeah,
-But, yeah, they're --
-Now, Dad,
you'll admit you spill.
-No.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-I saw it coming a mile away.
-So did I. Guess who didn't.
[ Laughter ]
-Right now my mom's going,
"Oh, my God! The spill!"
-"He spi-- Oh! Ohh! Oh! My God!"
-"What are you doing
in the studio?"
[ Laughter ]
-Where's that nice picture
we had of him?
-What? Oh, yeah. So this is --
How recent is this picture?
-Two days ago.
-Alright. So two days ago.
You spill everything you drink.
So this is -- You --
You got a beer, and then
immediately spilled it.
-I did. That's --
The spilling is not the part
that really troubles me,
but I come off in these things
very often as being
very temperamental.
-Yeah.
-You tell a story about me
wanting to destroy a table,
which I don't remember
the incident.
I don't doubt that I wanted
to destroy it, but...
-You bumped into a coffee table
in a Florida hotel lobby,
and then when it happened,
you raised a fist up
and started screaming
at the table.
And then when we got
in an elevator,
in a silent lobby -- because
everyone was looking at you --
Mom said,
"Why would you do that?"
And you said, "It hurt me.
I wanted to hurt it."
-Yeah. Out of emotion.
Absolutely true.
I just don't remember
that incident.
-You were in a fugue state
of rage.
-That might have been it.
That might have been it.
But, yeah, so I think --
But this is what's important
about what you guys
remember about us.
Not the spilling,
which is more recent.
But the thing is,
what it shows you is
that your kids
are paying attention
to every stupid thing you do,
and you never know
which stupid thing you do
is going to stick with them,
you know, well into later life.
And so -- And you never know.
And so it appears that we did
plenty of stupid stuff...
-Yeah.
-...and that you remembered
every single piece of nonsense
that we did.
-I was driving the other day,
and Ashe had a friend
in the back seat.
And I --
Axel, the 5-year-old,
was being irritating,
and I was getting angry
in the car.
And it was the most
heartbreaking thing
'cause Ashe --
I heard Ashe say to his friend,
"Oh, watch my dad. He's about to
lose it. It's so funny."
[ Laughter ]
And then you realize, like,
oh, it's so ineffective.
Like, the way I react
is so ineffective
that it's already like
a comedy show.
-When I got angry,
it was effective.
-Yeah.
For some reason,
they're not afraid of me at all.
-Yeah.
-One of the nice things
about the podcast is at the end
of each episode, Josh,
you write a song based on
the interview of the guest,
and you then sing
and record a song
that is sort of
an Easter egg for people
who listen all the way through.
-Yeah.
So it's a known song.
It'll be sort of
a karaoke version of a song
that I tweak the lyrics.
And -- And, yeah.
So I feel like it's a gift
to the people
who came onto the podcast.
I don't think a lot of people
who are guests on podcasts
then listen to that podcast.
-Yeah.
-So we have started sending out
an e-mail that's like,
"Hey, in case
you're not listening,
maybe you want
to listen to this."
But, like,
Timothy Olyphant called you.
Amy Poehler told you personally.
-Yeah, they like their songs.
-They like their songs.
-It's very nice.
-I wrote a song
for the Haim sisters.
I still haven't heard
whether or not they liked it.
-They're musicians.
So I felt like
I needed to elevate it.
-Yeah. Probably not a great sign
that you haven't heard from 'em.
-I haven't heard from 'em.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, but we're not --
We don't have each other's info.
-Yeah. That's true.
-Yeah.
-Did you guys have a favorite
guest that we've had so far?
-I thought Leslie Jones
was pretty good.
-Leslie Jones is pretty good.
-Pretty good.
And then you had to do the
disclaimer about the language.
-Yes.
-'Cause she does get a...
-We do want it to be the sort
of podcast you can listen to
with your family in the car,
with some exceptions.
-Yes.
But that song was so good
because she described a Marriott
that she went to
that was like a castle.
-Building a castle. Yeah.
-Built like a castle.
So then Joshy does the song
from "Misérables" --
"The Castle in the Clouds."
I mean, who would think
Leslie Jones --
a "Misérables" song?
I mean, it was just --
-It was a nice fit.
-It was a great fit, yeah.
-Dad, do you have a favorite ep?
-Our episode was really good.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-It was really --
What was the song for us?
-Hm.
-"Jack & Diane."
-Yeah.
-That's us.
-Two crazy kids
doing the best that we can.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I don't even know what
we're dealing with anymore.
-I'm also very excited.
We are --
We do an annual trip, as well.
We're gonna go to Pittsburgh.
We're gonna hope
the Steelers offense is better.
We're gonna record an episode
at an Airbnb there,
a special episode
where we're gonna
let our listeners
ask you guys questions.
So that's gonna be
a lot of fun.
And this -- We've done it
10 years, you guys.
-Yeah. Thanks.
-Well done.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."